ahora intentemos ordenar este nuevo
conjunto de datos de menor a mayor te
invito a que le pongas pausa al vídeo e
intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta
vayamos a la posición más significante
estos números en este caso son las
unidades pero ningún número tiene
unidades así es que ahora vayamos a la
siguiente posición más significante que
son las décimas este tiene cinco décimas
este tiene seis décimas éste tiene una
décima éste tiene cinco décimas y éste
tiene una décima así es que si empezamos
a ordenar por las décimas éste tiene una
décima éste también tiene una décima
este de aquí tiene cinco décimas este de
aquí tiene también cinco décimas y este
aquí tiene seis décimas estos números ya
están ordenados por las décimas ahora
estos dos números tienen las mismas
décimas vayamos a la siguiente posición
a las centésimas para ver cuál de estos
dos números es mayor este número tiene
seis centésimas este tiene cinco
centésimas este número es mayor tienen
el mismo número de décimas pero éste
tiene más centésimas y no importa el
número de milésimas pues centésimas es
más significativo así es que este es
mayor tiene más centésimas aunque de
hecho tiene más miles
también vayamos a los siguientes dos
estos dos números tiene el mismo número
de décimas tienen cinco pero este tiene
seis centésimas y éste tiene dos así es
que este número es mayor y finalmente
este es el número que tiene más décimas
es el mayor de todos ya no tenemos que
ver las otras posiciones así hemos
concluido